1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sérieux puis j'aimais c'était trop peur
alors on se rentre tout de suite dans 20
minutes après le 18e page de pub avec
tant que super séries comme les
chevaliers du sushi anatolie ernst
harald hagen ninja immature quelques
emplois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais plusieurs des cubains quoique
quoique non faites vous savez parce que
finalement quand on y réfléchit les pubs
font autant partie de notre enfance que
les émissions elle même tenez et voilà
vous voyez ça vous est revenu tout seul
les slogans ils sont restés gravés dans
vos têtes
on connaît tous un trou du cul qui
arrêtait pas de vous ressortir à la cour
de récré un truc du genre ya pas marqué
la poste où tu pousses le bouchon un peu
trop loin et maurice veut dire que notre
génération passé beaucoup de temps sur
la télé d'ailleurs je pense que la
génération des jeunes d'aujourd'hui se
souviendra beaucoup moins des pubs dans
le futur que nous faut comprendre que
pour les gens de notre génération
comparer en même temps il y avait une
grosse différence c'est qu'on n'avait
rien de mieux à un souvent on
n'avait pas de pc on avait pas de
portable pour envoyer des textos pendant
les pubs et y avait pas encore internet
et du coup pendant les plus bay avec de
choix où tu as fait sur une autre chaîne
pour espérer échapper trois minutes de
notre dessin animé qui m'intéressait
mais c'était un peu relou parce que bon
trois minutes t'as pas le temps de
comprendre ou alors battu ma télé pu
partir et c'est ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui alors préparez voir partir
avec des slogans plat la tête je précise
que certaines de ses vidéos sont de
mauvaise qualité mais c'est normal il
s'agit de bié publicité dont quasiment
impossible à retrouver en bonne qualité
c'est parti pour un hors série spécial
publicité
[Musique]
les pubs de céréales les tabelles fautes
qu'on se tape et en boucle le matin
juste avant d'aller à l'école moi je me
souviens surtout des petites chansons
genre l'ami ricoré vous savez avec la
famille la pub blanche du monde qui se
réunissent et paisiblement autour de
petits des jeux soleil non mais non
sérieusement vous êtes tous morts
regardez c'est pas possible
regardez vieille tous qui brille les
enfants sans billet en blanc la nappe et
blanches les parents sont en blanc blanc
blanc non mais là vous êtes au paradis
êtes mort ah là là si seulement j'avais
freiné à temps ne t'inquiète pas gérer
nous sommes heureux maintenant une où
seront heureux pour toujours toujours au
là encore une pub pour y corée bok et en
même temps tu me diras qu'ils en ont
sorti plein les poches de rock tous les
matins absolument jeunes ont bouffé une
quinzaine
bonjour quoi mais non mais ça tranche
complètement avec les pubs ricoré
habituel c'est quoi ça ces genres tout à
l'heure normale là vous voyez une pub
ricoré banal et soudain est ce qui est
génial c'est que tout le monde en écran
est terrifié mais la musique continue
mon appétit parfum gel douche seynod je
sais pas s'ils font ça encore maintenant
mais à l'époque j'avais vraiment
l'impression qu'il fallait forcément se
mettre à poil pour manger des yaourts
quand j'ai arrêté de nous mettre ces
espèces de nanas à poil là ils ont
commencé à nous mettre du schéma bizarre
qui vantait les mérites médicaux des
produits qu'on bouffe et et qui j'en
suis sûr et est complètement bidon je te
serai bon moment non j'ai envie de rien
je me sens un peu vallonné aujourd'hui
mais tu devrais commencer par mon truc
oui bio contient du bifidus actif
essensis on se sent bien
bio de danone actifs et aujourd'hui nous
enterrons bernadette qui nous a quittés
suite à une tumeur à l'estomac
elle aurait probablement dû à l'evora
médecin elle a eu ses premières de leur
revendre plutôt que de manger de yahoo
je me souviens aussi de ses pubs bizarre
pour les produits laitiers qui avait
dans les années 2020 des cas les essayer
de s'adresser à un public plus jeune
mais c'est tellement loin des vraies
préoccupations des jeunes les mecs et en
plus c'est vrai car y est plus sexy que
draguer une nana autour d'un bon vieux
camembert qui pue un vase y embrasse moi
tu peux bien qu'elle attend et puis bon
arrêter de s'en partout en buvant
mais c'est pas vrai quoi c'est pas moi
encore à examiner soulevé puis mettez
comme ça
[Musique]
une flamme
et pour du chien d'une manière générale
c'était le grand problème de toutes les
pubs quand il voulait s'adresser aux
jeunes y arrivais pas et comme on peut
partir à la reine chez pou places
assises mais c'est pas possible
mais si ces bleus si tôt tu te serais
tellement fait poignarder mais qu'en
2014 pour avoir dit ça oui cette pub ses
loyers bruts de pommes voilà ça n'existe
plus et rue je comprends pas la publ ces
genres il court au milieu de la route et
il fait renverser aujourd'hui nous
enterrons nicolas est mort renversé par
une voiture
sa passion sans limite aux les boissons
gazeuses sans alcool leur ont conduit à
courir au milieu du périph c'est
vraiment la journée des cons aujourd'hui
mais quand même je peux dire non si vous
regardez moi je vois pas de scénario
dans cette pub
bon personnellement je pense que c'est
une version raccourcie faisait beaucoup
ça à l'époque quand on te mettais une
pub en version longue histoire que le
message rentre pas dans quelques
semaines et ensuite on te mettais la
même pub en version raccourcie
sauf que là je pense qu'il faut changer
de monteur à la papa il y en a partout
aujourd'hui tout a changé c'est un
cadeau de maman en plus c'est
dégueulasse mayonnaise grèce crème
fraîche tout l'étagé ce paraissent grâce
à neige comme celle watts est incroyable
il ya plus aucune tâche papa tu as de la
chance que maman ne sache pas que ta
tâche et son petit cadeau non ma chérie
ça restera notre petit secret
voilà on le remonte façon brut de pomme
ça va donner ça à la papa et en a
partout été dégueulasse non ma chérie ça
restera notre petit secret oh là là
encore une pub de l'est c'est quoi c'est
quoi ce que si l'asie attention le les
vivats de candia peut provoquer cécité
temporaire futin dans les pertes deux
ans ah oui je sais je vois des double
sens partout allez promis la prochaine
pub se fait pas
[Musique]
manpower
vous aimez le poisson mais encore plus
que le poisson vous aimez les enfants
que thoenig le est là pour vous
nous sommes amis et tout bon aurait posé
ouais je sais que ça marcherait bons
joueurs comme sam au caire doucement
nous venons en au mit la preuve tout mon
nom est pour vous des bons bâtonnets de
colin tendre deux messieurs oh se
regarde oui les bonbons bâtonnets
honnêtement c'est un mec déguisé en
capitaine propose à votre enfant de
monter sur un avis rempli d'enfants pour
aller explorer des îles rempli d'enfants
et manger du poisson pané dit non
d'ailleurs je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
d'enfants dans l'histoire de la
publicité qui aurait dû appeler les
keufs fait un arrêt sur image ses tenues
sont complètement loupé poisson
tu imagines cette pub avec des adultes
la ola vous le soyons hulot but
lachinois capitaine s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
c'est que j'arrive maintenant j'entends
toujours ça
passons
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire pour
votre défense monsieur je déclare que
mes bâtonnets de poisson colin son
délicieux moelleux et croustillant le
vrai trésor du captain ok deux ans ferme
vous désirez je voudrais faire une
surprise à nos femmes que vous en
avertir
oui ma femme est en train de l'essayer
ok stop d'après vous de quoi parle cette
pub
qu'est ce qui va sortir de derrière ce
bureau bijoux vêtements parfums un
collier de nouilles
la cité du citron se fondant la
bergamote et n'a pas nui à sa fiche en
matinée
[Musique]
théoriquement il paraît que vous en avez
reçus
wind farm est en train de laisser sa
femme est en train de laisser y est
relié ma femme est en train de baisser
vous désirez je voudrais faire une
surprise à sa chérie
bon anniversaire ça tombe bien j'adore
chier arrêtez de parler des maires de
vos femmes déjà toi clark kent là je te
connais pas mais taper tram c'est sûr et
si tu as une pas vraiment la tête du mec
qui l'a tué qu'il a mangé ensuite je les
connais pas vous fermez la dernière
chance dont j'ai envie c'est d'imaginer
ma copine entraîne juillet et puis bon
sang arrêtez de vouloir faire une
comédie musicale sur un truc dans la
première utilité et de se torcher le cul
c'est pour offrir genou lamballe mushi
précise
ah les miens ne pêche pas je vais pas
tenir et on me stehlin pourquoi toi
bombe s'est fait manger des bâtonnets de
poisson en colle un délicieux et
moelleux à des enfants qui en raffole le
vrai trésor du cape town n'ont pas fait
tomber un bâtonnet de collège mais le
ramasser et voici les nouveaux corps
enfin les pubs de jouer ça c'était
génial
rien qu'à regarder une page de pub à
l'époque vous pouviez savoir exactement
à quelle époque de l'année vous étiez
quand c'était le mois d'août telle était
plein de pubs de cahiers de stylos pour
la rentrée des classes de merde mais ma
période de l'année préféré c'était
évidemment quand le mois de novembre
approché et que les spots se remplissait
peu à peu de pub pour jouer c'est là que
tu sentais que les vacances approchent
et alors il y avait tout mais moi mon
petit péché mignon quand même c'était
les pubs de jeux vidéo alors tu avais
vraiment les pubs petit défoncé je me
souviens surtout de la pub pour tortues
ninja sur nes c'est fou même en sachant
que le jeu m'a fait souffrir ça me donne
quand même envie d'y jouer de voir ça et
puis tu avais les pubs qui défonce et
moins
[Musique]
sur super nintendo ok merci je peux voir
une image du jeu s'il vous plaît ok
c'est quoi le message de cette pub
aladdin ce jeu existe bah oui évidemment
zelda ocarina of time alors là si vous
vous souvenez en france avec quelque
chose d'assez sobre classique musique
sympa des images du jeu texte qu'ils ont
envie ça va c'est cool mais je m'arrête
dessus pour vous montrer les versions
étrangères déjà la version américaine
au début ça va ça commence bien c'est
comme chez nous mais à la fin est-ce que
tu va choper la fille ou jouer comme une
fille ok très bien joué comme une fille
assise attendez vous voulez dire comme
dans la version japonaise joué comme une
fille au kg très bon ok on va faire un
test fermé les yeux fermés les yeux sans
déconner alesi ferme les yeux
allez faites moi confiance voilà c'est
bon ils sont fermés là ok non je
plaisante
allez on y va fermer les yeux je lance
la pub ok alors peut-être que mon
cerveau a été totalement corrompu par
les hentais je dis pas mais cette pub
n'a aucun intérêt on n'apprend rien du
tout mais arrête jamais ce que vous avez
quoi je laisse tomber de toute façon en
fait je me demande juste été quoi la
motivation des gens quand ils sont
rentrés dans un magasin pour acheter ce
jeu après avoir vu cette pub
thierry jeter acheter un jeu zelda 64,1
génial j'adore les zelda
toujours garderie oui les pubs
avec le numéro du père noël c'est fou
parce que aussi loin que je me souvienne
dans ma mémoire quand j'étais petit
c'est numéro existait déjà
je me souviens encore du numéro c'était
08 36 c'est pas du tout ça dont je me
souviens c'est pas du tout ça dont je me
souviens succès mais oui voilà c'est
celui-là c'est 08 36 65 65 65 c'est ça
la vraie pub c'est quoi l'autre la ville
change de numéro chaque année au courant
c'est ça non plus c'est pas le bon
salut c'est le père noël je suis au pôle
nord mais je peux pas parler très
longtemps parce que méchant du fmi a
évoqué riant de démagogique
allez vous faire ouais vous
n'aurez jamais 3 et touchait pas mon
traîneau et bien évidemment la
transition est logique père noël pub de
jouer à le pub de jouer à j'aimais
beaucoup comme la vie était plus simple
pour les enfants à l'époque des pubs de
jouer c'était pas compliqué est était un
garçon tu faisais la guerre t'étais une
fille tu faisais des bébés ah j'aime
bien les petites cases c'est vrai que
quand tu vois ses pubs la guerre salaire
trop cool regarde le gamin intérieure
que je le demande ce qu'il dit c'est fou
quand ils pensent toutes les pubs
c'était exactement sur le même modèle je
veux dire que pourrait prendre n'importe
laquelle de mes figurines et faire
exactement la même chose
regarde voilà moïse morizet de retour et
il est sans pitié avec les terribles
polythéistes bevan aubert s'est ouvert
fermeront deux convertis tes ennemis
avec les deux super arme la tablette des
dix commandements et le bâton de berger
prête à recommencer et à samantha 40
cesse la terre promise
vous voyez c'est pas dur et donc de
l'autre côté des chromosomes on avait
les fûts pour filles coupé ou barbie peu
importe
dégueulasse
[Musique]
ils entendaient vivre tue c'est bon
mais comme invalide et oui et vu tu lui
fais en permanence manger ce qu'il vient
de chier juste avant tu m'étonnes que sa
deuxième fonction sont pleurer
c'est quoi ces nombreux
gérard mort subite du nourrisson
d'une manière générale je me souviens
que même quand j'étais petit je
comprenais pas pourquoi les filles
voulaient absolument avoir un lardons
qui pleure comme jouer le principe de
poupon ou d'une plus c'est d'être mignon
c'est pas de reproduire tous les trucs
chiants de la vraie vie bb terreurs
nocturnes te réveilleras toutes les
nuits cas je le conseille embrasse lui
ça ne changera rien il veut pas
s'arrêter puritans ici découvrir
maternité avec des terreurs nocturnes et
puis certains jouets pour filles
y regarder ça s était juste terrifiant
[Musique]
il m'a matin
evi ne meurent pas le centre
écoutez on voit la pays des
cauchemars à la maison quand tu as une
soeur qui a ce genre de trucs
ça va être dur de faire plus
malsaines salle
il en visite
pas par où commencer dès le début que si
oui en fait si je sais y'a des
chanteuses qu'ils ont vraiment aller
dans un studio pour chanter ça
non et pour le reste
non mais c'est mon écran tâche je suis
même pas c'est quoi le plus malsain dans
cette pub c'est de voir un gros plan de
pénis dans les doigts d'une enfant c'est
d'abord que tous les gens du parc ont
tout laissé tomber pour venir voir de
près les parties génitales de votre bébé
ok s'il vous plaît dites moi qu'on peut
pas trouver pire dit moi qu'on est au
fond du panier des rebuts de l'humanité
mahmoudi c'est une poupée merveilleux
qui attend un petit bébé
[Musique]
hérité cette pub art et essai de
c'est quoi cette tête ils ont pris la
photo d'une fille de minutes avant son
suicide pour faire cette poupée on dira
l'incarnation du désespoir maman
surprise maman surprise elle a 14 ans
déjà de gosse sa vie est foutue
et elle le sait maman surprise emmène
maman sur les rails caf et trouve lui un
hlm
j'ai vu son appartement je ferais
n'importe quoi pour ça n'importe quoi
maman series
comment maman surprise dès maintenant et
reçoit un cadeau ta première pilule du
lendemain enfin bref c'est tout pour
cette vidéo vous savez quoi qu'on en
dise les publicités qu'on aime ou on
n'aime pas ça nous a autant marqué dans
notre enfance que les dessins animés et
c'est pour ça que je devais planque pour
quelques jours oh oh oh vraiment suivi
en foire et du fisc ou saisies répondent
en traîneau j'ai entendu des gens pas
content le moussaillon calmez-vous je me
rends tenez prenez tout mon or les
bombes a tonné du captain délicieux et
savoureux dégueulasse pour ce produit
jamais goûté
[Musique]
oh